>> Steven Levingston: Good
afternoon, and welcome.
I'm Steve Levingston,
nonfiction book editor
of the Washington Post,
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First, a couple quick
housekeeping tings.
We'd like to extend
a word of thanks
to the Festival's
cochairman David Rubenstein
and the other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to contribute
your financial support,
there's some information
about that in the program.
Before we begin, I've
been asked to remind you
that these events are being
recorded by the Library
of Congress, which may broadcast
them at some future date.
After our author's presentation,
there will be time
for questions.
But if you don't
want to become part
of the Library's permanent
collection, it may be better
to let someone else
ask the questions.
And now, also, I need to ask you
if you wouldn't mind
silencing your cellphones.
That also would be wonderful.
Thank you.
Most writers can only
dream of the success
that Jeffery Deaver lives
as an everyday reality.
To outsiders, his life as a
writer must be as thrilling
as the books he writes.
If you're here today,
you probably don't
need an introduction
to this master craftsman.
You've probably read more than
a few of Deaver's 30 plus novels
and his scores of short stories.
Once you start reading,
you can't stop.
That's the amazing
talent of Jeffrey Deaver.
He makes best sellerdom
[phonetic] look easy.
But his sales aren't the
only measure of his success.
He has collected a shelf full
of awards, the Nero Wolf Award,
three Ellery Queen
Readers' Awards,
the Ian Fleming Steel Dagger and
the Short Story Dagger Award.
He is among that rare group of
elite writers chosen to carry
on the James Bond franchise.
In its review of Carte Blanche,
the Washington Post said
Deaver brilliantly captured the
immortal character of James Bond
and called the tail
magnificently manic,
impeccably researched,
with Deaver's trademark
misdirection and twists.
Deaver's best-known series
features the characters you all
know, quadriplegic
detective Lincoln Rhyme
and his partner, Amelia Sachs.
His first in the series,
The Bone Collector was made
into a movie starring Denzel
Washington and Angelina Jolie.
His latest, the 14th
in the series
out now, is The Cutting Edge.
If you haven't read it, I
don't want to spoil it for you.
I'll let the reviewers entice
you The New York Times said
Deaver is at his graciously
cruel best in this one.
His flare for ghastly
irony is on full display.
Publishers Weekly gave The
Cutting Edge a starred review,
calling it a roller
coaster ride of a thriller.
Well, what more needs
to be said?
He's the best at what he does.
Please join me in
welcoming Jeffery Deaver.
[ Applause ]
>> Jeffery Deaver:
Well thank you, Steve.
And thank you to Karen who's
been wonderful, my escort today
around this amazing festival.
Thank you to the Library
of Congress and especially,
especially thank you, readers.
You make it all worthwhile
for us.
Now, as Steve said, he gave
you a bit of a background,
but I'll fill in a little bit.
I have written about 40
novels, 80 or so short stories,
an album of country-western
songs, believe it or not.
I respect you too much to sing.
Don't worry.
A nonfiction law book.
I say nonfiction law book.
I do practice fiction,
so you can make
of that what you
wish, a radio play.
But there's one thing in my
long career I have not tried,
and I thought I would tonight.
Plagiarism.
I've been writing a book about
writing fiction for some years.
It's taken me a little longer.
I do write quite a
bit of my own work,
so it's taken me
a while to do it.
But the format of this book
is where I extract quotations
from other writers who are far
more intelligent and articulate
than I and use that as kind of
a springboard to talk about,
I guess what I'd say the
chronological process
of writing a novel.
And that's what we're
going to do tonight.
We're going to look at the
eight or nine chapter headings,
and don't worry, you'll be out
of here at the allotted time.
And I'll tell you a little bit
about how I approach this
crazy world of writing.
First, however, I have
to give you, as I'm going
to do throughout the
evening, some quotations.
But these are devil's
advocates, and we'll start
with Lillian Hellman, the great
writer from the Round Table
in the Algonquin Hotel next
to The New Yorker at the time,
New Yorker Magazine at the time.
And Lillian Hellman said this.
If I had to give young writers
any advice about writing,
I would say, never listen
to writers giving you
advice about writing.
And the brilliant
Somerset Maugham said this.
There are three simple rules
for writing a great novel.
Sadly, no one knows
what they are.
With all respect to those fine
if somewhat disparate
authors, I disagree.
Given a desire to write,
given a command of whatever,
I was going to say English,
but whatever language you're
comfortable composing in.
And given this thing called
sweat labor, because a lot
of writing is simply sitting
down and muscling your way
through a story or book.
Given those, it's a
skill like anything else.
And you can learn how to do it.
So we're going to begin, again,
sort of the chronological
process of creating a novel.
And chapter one of
my book is why write?
Why on Earth do we
do this crazy thing.
William Safire said this.
I write because I enjoy
expressing myself,
and writing forces me
to think more coherently
than when I'm just
shooting my mouth off.
There's a serious side
to why we write too.
Reynolds Price, a great
North Carolinian writer.
I write because it's really
the only thing I'm very good
at in the world.
And I've got to stay busy
to keep from going crazy.
To keep from dying
of depression.
Jonathan Safran Foer,
why do I write?
It's not that I want
people to think I'm a smart
or that I'm a good writer.
I write because I want
to end loneliness.
That before and after everything
else is what books do.
They show us that communication
is possible across distance.
And of course, we come
to William Burroughs,
and who doesn't want this
on his or her bucket list.
As a young child, I
wanted to be a writer
because writers were
rich and famous.
They lounged around
Singapore where smoking opium
and wearing a yellow
pongee silk suit.
They sniffed cocaine in Mayfair
and lived in the native quarter
of Tangier languidly
caressing their pet gazelle.
We've all been there, right.
Why do I write?
I write because I was a nerd.
But I was nerd when the
word meant something.
You know what a nerd is now.
You have a billion dollars,
some kind of social
networking company.
And frankly, you appeared
before Senate subcommittees
about why you handed the US
election over to the Russians.
I'm sorry.
I swore I was not
going to talk politics.
I was a Leave it to
Beaver kind of nerd.
I said that once
at a presentation,
and this young girl
came up to me.
She was quite cross.
She said Mr. Deaver,
Justin Bieber is not a nerd.
[ Laughter ]
I was pudgy, clumsy,
socially inept,
no talent for sports whatsoever.
Uniformly ignored by pom-pom
girls and cheerleaders.
It was for a pretty good reason
that I was the last person
picked on the sports team.
Maybe some of you ladies
and gentlemen will know
that experience, that
mortifying experience.
They would put me in, I
think it was right field
where statistically
fewer balls were hit
where I could do
the least damage.
And understandably, because
I would be sitting there.
And I had the, I'd get the
glove on the correct hand.
Then I'd be looking up
saying, that cloud is cool.
You know, that cloud, I could
make a story out of that cloud.
But then I'd be, even then I
was writing as a young boy.
And I think I can remember it.
I'd write poetry.
The score is tied
three boys on base.
I see the batter's happy face
as he grips the bat
and looks my way.
All I can do is hope and
pray that he won't hit to me.
But we all know how it goes.
He whacks that ball
and it breaks my nose.
Well, you know, it
didn't matter,
because I had something
better than sports.
I had the Glen Allen
Public Library
where I spent my
after-school hours.
Where I spent many summers.
I fell in love with these
things called books.
They could take us
out of ourselves,
out of our daily cares.
They could teach us about things
that we have no other
way of learning.
And they did something else.
Do you remember when maybe you
were the new kid at school,
and you were mortified.
You didn't know a soul.
And you'd look across the
playground and kind of sidle
up to somebody too
shy to say anything.
But then you noticed
they were holding a copy
of Lord of the Rings.
Or Laura Ingalls Wilder's
Little House on the Prairie.
Or Ray Bradbury.
And only then could
make eye contact.
And you say, you get to the
part about the dragon yet?
Or did you meet this
character or that?
And then your eyes locked, and
even though you didn't know
that person from Adam
or Eve, you really did.
Why? Because of books.
Books brought you together.
I knew then at a young
age that I wanted
to devote my life to writing.
That was chapter one.
Why do we write?
Chapter two, finding a
subject to write about.
Francine Matthews said
this, and actually,
I was with Francine
Matthews when I heard her say
that at the National
Book Festival.
Francine said, I always
heard write what you know.
I disagree.
I say write about what you love.
You can always research
the rest.
Flannery O'Connor, anybody
who has survived childhood
has enough material about life
to last for the rest of
their days as a writer.
Where do I get my ideas,
what do I write about?
I was on a panel in England
a few years ago with one
of the great [inaudible]
of cozy fiction.
And you're in the genre room,
so you know cozy fiction are
little softer kind of books,
Agatha Christie books.
And the question
was posed to her.
She was the headliner.
And she said, well
where do I get my ideas.
I sit down in my parlor
with a cup of tea,
and I wait for my muse,
whose name was Philomena,
to tap me on the head
with her magic wand
and poof, there's an idea.
Well, I laughed, of course.
Who wouldn't?
I chortled.
It wasn't a laugh.
It was like one of
those visceral chortles,
and not a soul in the
audience was smiling.
They were staring reverently
at this wonderful writer in awe
of her and Philomena, the muse.
And you know how you try
to turn that into a cough.
It doesn't work.
And so then the question
went to me.
And you know in this
day and age,
everything you have ever
said is on the internet,
along with everything
you've done in Cabo
and should not have done.
But it's all there.
So, I had to tell the truth.
I said well, you know,
frankly I sit down.
In America we don't really
have parlors and such.
We have studies or dens.
I have a beverage too.
It ain't tea.
And I try to simply
think of a way
to scare the ever-living
hell out of you.
You know, you get into a taxicab
at an airport, a strange city,
and it goes the opposite way
of where you think
you should be going.
And then you realize there
are no handles on the door,
the beginning of
The Bone Collector.
Mickey Spillane said
people don't read books
to get to the middle.
We don't pick up a 500-page book
and say I cannot wait to get
to page 250 and put it down.
So I look, I look very,
very hard at a story
that will allow me
to move very quickly.
That will allow me to scare you.
That will be very tense.
A book to me is the most
emotionally engaging experience
we can possibly have.
We love, I binge on TV.
Who doesn't love, you know,
the new Get Shorty on Epix.
Or Breaking Bad.
We all play Candy
Crush or Crunch.
I don't, so otherwise I
would know what the name is.
But you know, we
have fun doing that.
We look at wonderful paintings,
listen to symphony orchestras.
But we participate
with the author
in the creation of the story.
We see it in our head.
Whether we listen to it
on audio or we read it,
we are living, breathing
partners.
And so I look for something
that will create the most
engaging emotional experience
we can.
You should miss bus stops.
You should show up
for work late.
So that's, anyway,
that's what I look for,
ideas that will let me
race through the book.
Chapter three, and this
is a bit controversial.
I'm sure there's some
writers out there.
And the world is divided
into the two groups I'm
about to talk about, and
I'll describe it in a moment.
A quotation from
Joyce Carol Oates.
The first sentence of your
story cannot be written
until you know what
the last sentence is.
Ernest Hemingway,
prose is architecture,
not interior design.
Gustave Flaubert, books are
made the way pyramids are made,
according to a long-pondered
plan.
And then the blocks of stone
are set one atop the other.
I subscribe to this theory.
The world I was talking
about was divided
into plotters and pantsers.
Plotters as in those of us who
outline and pantsers as in seat
of the pants, and they wing it.
And I'm sorry, I'm a
bit adamant about this.
I don't get on an airplane that
has not been built according
to engineering diagrams
long ahead of time.
I don't go into surgery if
the doctor has not, you know,
planned out exactly
what is going to happen.
Why should I read a book that
has not been crafted that way?
What I do is spend eight
months on my outline.
It's a full-time job.
I do the research at the
same time, so it's kind
of the preparation
aspect of the book.
It is so important to do.
And there are two main
reasons why I believe firmly
that one should outline.
First of all, thrillers,
and I'll even extend
that to any genre
fiction, and you know what,
I'm going to extend it
to any story you tell
at all, is about structure.
It is about structure
and as much as
or more so than fine prose.
I would much rather
read pedestrian writing.
I write in a very meat and
potatoes kind of style and
yet have a structured
story that follows,
say a symphonic structure.
And I'll tell you what
I mean about that.
If Beethoven had created five
vivace movements after another,
you're going to get
bored by the last two.
On the same token, if
there are five adagios,
you're going to fall asleep.
What does he do?
He intersperses those sort of
assigned curve to the crescendo,
[singing] da, da, da,
da, da, da, da, da.
[Speaking] And then at
the end there's a coda,
a reconciliation of the themes.
And what an exciting
experience that is.
And Beethoven knew how to get
us excited and get us going.
A thriller should
be the same thing.
And an outline let's
you do that.
You can look at your post-it
notes, and you can say oh now,
I've got two, I've
got two bodies,
one right next to another.
We've got to change that scene.
Outline lets you structure.
And the second reason
to outline.
You don't have to raise your
hand, but just ask yourself,
have you ever read a book that
should not have been written?
How does that happen?
Let's say you come up with
a beautiful set piece,
and set piece in the literature
and the movie business is
simply a very exciting scene
where it doesn't
necessarily have
to be action, though
it often is.
The beginning of Deadpool,
the movie, for instance,
which some of you have seen,
whether you want
to admit it or not.
It was a great film.
But, you come up with this great
idea for your first chapter,
the prologue, chapter
one, so exciting.
And you sit down, and this
chapter writes itself.
Five hours, six hours, bang,
you've got 30 pages
of a perfect chapter.
Wow, that is so good.
And the energy is up, and the
steam is up, and you just,
chapter two, chapter
three, chapter four.
Chapter five is kind
of a brick wall.
But you've created 180 or so
pages of well-crafted prose.
and I guarantee that everybody
in this room can write
well-crafted prose.
You can do it if you know
what you want to write.
You can do it.
Well, you've got let's say 200
pages of this bang-up ending,
and you don't know what
the middle is going
to be, that dreaded middle.
And you think oh, I could
fill it with the clichés
that we see, a car chase.
Or we've never seen this.
The police detective has
a fight with his captain,
and the captain demands
the badge and gun.
And he has to go renegade.
I'll put that in.
And then there's no ending,
just a Deus ex Machina ending,
and the villain comes
from out of left field.
We never saw the villain
until the final scene.
Well, you're confronted
with two choices now.
And you're going to get
my take on it by the,
some of the adjectives I use.
The first take is the
morally reprehensible,
intellectually dishonest,
cowardly approach.
And that's to tack on that
middle, that bad middle
and do the cliché-ridden
ending and put it
out in the stream of commerce.
And why is that a crime?
Because we authors owe you 100%.
And that book would
be less than 100%.
That's option one.
Option two is to do the morally
courageous, uplifting, correct
and righteous thing, throw
it out, every single page.
And that includes that wonderful
bang-up set piece beginning.
Because if you can write a good
beginning, a good set piece
for a bad novel, think
of he wonderful set piece
beginning you can start with a,
start your book with
in a good novel.
Now, let's cut to the outline.
You take post-it notes.
You write on the first post-it
note big set piece beginning.
And that's all you write.
That goes in the upper left-hand
corner of your corkboard.
Something you can use, something
very much like the size of that.
And then you start sticking
things in the middle
and little notes to the size.
Another murder here.
Detective has a fight here.
Three weeks go by, and you're
staring at that corkboard
and you say, you know,
there's no middle.
There's just, I cannot
think of anything.
There's no middle.
And you look at the end.
No, there's no end.
It's just a cliché.
You wad up 30 post-it
notes, throw it out.
You've wasted a week's time, and
you start over on something new.
Certainly, you can write
the prose if you want.
And maybe you can kind of think
through things ahead of time.
But I myself like to
get it all planned out.
Okay, now we're going to jump
to chapter four, and we're going
to talk about writing
the novel itself.
And this is putting words into,
putting words onto the page.
Nathanial Hawthorne, a
writer's words should dissolve
into pure thought.
A writer's words should
dissolve into pure thought.
I love that.
What he means by
that, of course,
is that you shouldn't
fill up your story
with pyrotechnic prose.
You should not put in
similes that are off the wall
so that the reader reads a
passage and says wow, that is,
that's fire cracking writing.
That is so damn good.
I have no clue what it means.
But's just great writing.
Nathanial Hawthorne's comments,
Stephen King said any
words you have to hunt
for in a thesaurus
is the wrong word.
Stephen King, another
one, said the road
to hell is paved with adverbs.
I love that.
And since I've mentioned some
wonderful [inaudible] wise sage
literary philosophers, I'm going
to quote now my favorite,
Dr. Seuss.
It has often been said
there's so much to be read.
You can never keep all
those words in your head.
So the writer who
breeds more words
than he needs is making a
chore for the reader who reads.
That's why my belief is,
the briefer the brief is,
the greater the sigh of
the reader's relief is.
And that's why your books
have such power and strength
when you publish with shorth.
Shorth is better than length.
Less is always more.
For my writing the
book itself, as I said,
I have a very pedestrian style.
You know, our language
skills are pretty much formed
by the time we're eight
or nine years old.
You expand your vocabulary
considerably.
You learn things about the
dative and ablative cases.
But nonetheless, at
a very young age,
you kind of get your
tone and your voice.
And that's what you
should listen to.
Once the outline is done,
then I can sit down,
and I can write the
book in any order.
I can write the beginning at the
end, the end at the beginning.
I have the, you know, the
chapters all planned out.
I may come to a scene
of a vicious murder,
and I just don't feel
like viciously murdering
somebody at that point.
You know, we all have
those days, right.
Some of you didn't
respond to that.
Maybe you want to murder
somebody every day.
I myself save those days for
when, well let me explain.
I'm a writer, correct.
What do we writers like most in
the world, excuses not to write.
And what's the best excuse not
to write, yes, the internet
and YouTube, watching videos
of baby goats in pajamas.
And enough people laugh
so you know exactly what I'm
talking about, don't you?
So what happens, I
wake up one morning,
and oh no, the internet is out.
My cable is gone.
So in a panic, I called the
unnamed Time Warner Cable.
I wasn't going to say that.
And I say, please get
somebody out here.
And they say, okay, tomorrow
morning we'll get a repairman
there at 8 in the morning,
and we'll get you
all straightened out.
Eight in the morning comes, nine
comes, ten comes, 11, 12, 4:00,
the guy strolls in, and he
looks at my cable box and says,
that's a, I don't know, an
XK-42, but I can't work on that.
Those are the days when I want
to viciously murder somebody.
And guess what the name
of my next victim is
and what unnamed cable
company he works for.
So, anyway.
When you put the prose
together, you have an outline.
You can write it in any order.
Write it in a natural style.
Okay, chapter five, we're going
to look at editing and revising.
Ernest Hemingway said,
there are no great writers.
There are only great rewriters.
And I firmly, firmly
believe that.
If it sounds like writing,
Elmore Leonard said, I rewrite.
For my part, because I bang the
story out very, very quickly,
I will produce 130,000
words in two months.
But that draft, that's my
first draft, it's two things.
It's too long, and it's sloppy.
Because it's easier to write
long than it is to write short.
And it's also easier to write
more sloppily than it is
to write very concisely
and well.
So, what I do is I let the
manuscript sit for as long
as I can to get kind
of a fresh take.
And then I revise it.
I do, I must revise 50 times.
Now that's not 100% revision.
Toward the end of that it's
much more finely tuned.
But so, I don't know,
realistically 35
to 40 or 50 drafts.
Now, if any of you are taking
notes because you think some
of these comments
might be helpful,
there's one thing you do
absolutely have to do.
The first revisions on your
computer, because it's very easy
to globally search and replace.
If you want to change
names, move chapters
and paragraphs around, but
then you have to print it out.
Because there may be
some psychologists,
some reading specialists
here, there may very well be,
and they could tell you
far better than I could.
But there's a different
psychological process
of experiencing a book on paper.
I guarantee it.
And I have an e-reader, and
I read books a lot, e-books.
But it is a richer experience.
And that means for writers,
that we then see things
that we would otherwise
have missed on the screen.
And I'm not talking about typos,
that's true for those,
of course.
But I'm also talking
about conceptual problems.
And you know, it's
kind of artful
if an author uses the
same word in a paragraph,
kind of a distinctive word.
An example would be,
this is farfetched,
nobody would ever do this.
But the detective walked into
the avocado-colored room,
and he reached down and
searched for the gun.
And his hand touched something
that was soft as an avocado.
And then he said, you know,
the bad guy stared at hi
with avocado pits for eyes.
If you haven't read my books,
they are better than that.
Just don't panic.
Don't panic.
But that could, something
like that could be
missed on the screen.
But when you go to
read the book on paper,
those things will
jump out for you.
Again, then I read it
aloud, the whole book.
I read it aloud.
Because that helps
you find things.
And you know, the
novel form is very new
in the history of civilization.
The storytelling tradition has
always been oral, either plays
or poetry, read poetry.
And so the idea of people
sitting down and opening a book,
you know, only goes back
a few hundred years.
So I think there should be some
magic in the sound of the words.
And so I read it aloud.
And you can see, you know,
people might stumble two words
together, don't quite fit.
Two sibilance running
into each other.
So that's a trick that
I use quite frequently
with my stories.
Okay, now we have
to talk about this.
Oh my God, chapter six.
Writer's block.
I was going to give you the wise
sage literary philosopher name,
but you're going to
have to guess this one.
It, it was, it was, it was, it
was, it was a, it was a, a dark,
it was a dark and stormy night.
Oh, good writing is hard work.
And who was that?
Snoopy, the beagle, of course.
Terry Pratchett said this.
There's no such thing
as writer's block.
It was invented by people in
California who can't write.
Larry Kahaner.
I don't believe in
writer's block.
Do doctors have doctor's block?
Do plumbers have
plumber's block?
No, we all have days when
we don't feel like working.
But why do writers turn it
into something so damn special
by giving it a faintly
romantic name?
Well, I subscribe to
all of the above there.
There is no such thing
as writer's block.
However, there is idea block.
If you know what you want
to write, you can write it.
I guarantee that.
If you have an idea that's
viable, you can write it.
But coming up with those ideas
can be extremely difficult.
That's why the outlines
take me eight months to do.
And that can be, that can
involve pacing back and forth
in front of that
corkboard trying to figure
out what the hell is
going to happen here?
How can I get the clue
in the middle of the book
so that the reader gets
to the end and says, oh,
I should have seen that
he was the villain.
I should have figured that out.
But when you do that,
then you can, again,
write the book in any order.
There is a kind of
writer's block
that Larry was somewhat
referring to.
You know, a surgeon
wakes up in the morning,
and she's got an eight-hour
brain aneurism she has to repair
and just doesn't want to do it
because it's a huge
amount of work.
We wake up, we have to copy
edit for eight, ten hours.
Well, you know, I'm
sorry, we get paid to make
up stuff for a living.
So, you know, we live
a pretty good life.
So you roll up your sleeves.
You get into the room where you
write, and you just do the work.
That's not block.
That's everybody tendency
to be a bit, you know,
frankly just a bit lazy.
And who isn't and who
doesn't mind that?
Chapter seven, critics
and criticism.
Sebastian Younger.
I wrote my first novel
in seventh grade,
longhand in a green
composition notebook.
My teacher read it aloud
to the entire class,
chapter by chapter.
No wonder I didn't
have a single friend.
Neil Gaiman.
Remember, when people
tell you something's wrong
or doesn't work for them
in one of your books,
they're almost always right.
When they tell you how to fix
it, they're almost always wrong.
David Mitchell.
This is great.
When you show someone
something you've written,
you give them a sharpened
stake, you're lying
down in your coffin, and you
say, whenever you're ready.
For me, I've had, you know, I've
been doing this for a long time,
and I've had lots of rejection.
I think one of my favorite
rejections was this.
Do you all know what
self-addressed stamped
envelopes are?
Now it's a different world.
You submit your book
electronically in most cases.
But a self-addressed
stamped envelope was
when you had the 300-page
manuscript in an envelope.
You included in that
package to the publisher
or agent an envelope addressed
back to you with enough postage
on it so they would then
send you the manuscript back
with a probably five to
ten lengthy, pithy critique
of your book, which told you
in, you know, ten lines how
to fix it and send
it back to them.
And then whereupon they
would send you a contract
for the next ten books.
Well, I got back my
self-addressed stamped envelope,
but I picked it up
and shook it, and no,
it didn't contain gold and,
you know, it didn't seem
to have money and lots
of contracts in it.
It had my manuscript, of course.
And here's the form it was in.
It had clearly fallen on
the floor of the publisher,
because the pages were
every which a way.
Those were the days when
you could still smoke,
and there was a cigarette
butt mixed in with it.
And instead of this wise, very
erudite letter telling me how
to correct the manuscript, it
was my own cover letter upside
down with a shoe print on it.
And I thought at the
time, well clearly,
somebody dropped it accidently.
They loved it but
they didn't have time
to put the pages back together.
Thought they'd send it back, and
the footprint was an accident.
Now, I think they drew straws
to see who got to step on it.
But, you know, I
find that comments,
that feedback is
very, very important.
I was at a book signing
once in California,
and a woman in her 90s came up
to me afterwards and said oh,
Mr. Deaver, we have a
reading club, a reader's club
in the retirement community
next to the bookstore.
We read all your
books, and we love them.
But this latest book, you know,
we had some trouble with it.
And I got elected to
come up and, you know,
express our criticism.
And I said, no, no, I like that.
I want to hear what doesn't
want as much as I want
to hear what does work.
So the next time, I won't do it.
She said well, okay, it's about
the violence in your books.
I said, please tell me.
She said, well, you
know, we read this book,
and we think you're
going soft on us.
The Bone Collector, you
scalded that couple to death
in that first chapter.
And in chapter 18, you had rats
crawling all over that girl.
In this book, one
guy got stabbed,
another one got shot,
and they both lived.
We want you to get
back to your roots.
Well, does that mean I'm
going to, you know, make the,
what are those stupid
movies, Saw, you know,
these ridiculous torture movies?
No, that's ridiculous.
Okay, well let's, we're going
to get to chapter eight now,
and I do want to leave a
little time for questions.
But chapter eight,
humorous interlude
on famous rejection letters.
Lest you think this business
is sad and full of drudgery.
Oh no, there's a lot
of humor out there too.
Here's some real quotes
from rejection letters.
I'm sorry, Mr. Kipling,
you don't know how
to use the English language.
Your poems are remarkable
for their defects and devoid
of truly poetic qualities,
Emily Dickenson.
It is impossible to sell animal
stories in the United States,
George Orwell's Animal Farm.
This book will set publishing
back 25 years, Norman Mailer.
You're welcome to John le Carré.
He has no future.
And my two favorites are,
you'd have a decent book
if you got rid of
that Gatsby fellow.
And I think my all-time
favorite is this.
My dear sir, I have to ask,
does it have to be a whale?
[ Laughter ]
Chapter nine, the
daily life of a writer.
J. K. Rowling.
Be ruthless about
protecting your writing days.
That is, don't give in
to analysts' requests
to have essential or quote, long
overdue meetings on those days.
The funny thing is that
although I've been writing
as an actual job for several
years now, I still seem to have
to find time in which to do it.
People don't seem to grasp
that I still have to sit
down in peace and
write the books,
apparently believing they
pop up like mushrooms
without my connivance.
I must, therefore,
guard the time allotted
to writing the way a
Hungarian horntail guards its
firstborn egg.
Ray Bradbury.
You must write every
single day of your life.
You must lurk in libraries,
climb stacks like ladders
to sniff books like
perfume and wear them
like hats upon your crazy head.
Lee Child.
Don't get it right,
get it written.
And Henry Miller.
Keep human.
See people.
Go places.
Have friends.
Drink if you feel like.
For me, it's a job.
That's all it is,
a full-time job.
I was an attorney
for some years.
I was a journalist
I spend more time now at
this job than I did then,
even working on Wall
Street many years ago.
I find that it is,
it is something
that you can devote
your entire life to.
You are never bored as an
author if you have your computer
with you're a pen and paper.
Ideas pop up.
I write them down.
I may use them.
I may not.
But it's very consuming.
And when I tell my students,
you have to ask yourself,
what kind of relationship
you want with writing.
I write full-time, but
it's a very arduous job.
It's not for everybody.
I like to spend time alone.
I don't play well with others.
That's just the way it is.
But you may not want to do that.
You might want to write
a book every ten years.
You might want to self-publish.
That's all perfectly valid,
but to live your daily life
as a writer, you have
to kind of figure
out where you fall
in this crazy world.
Well, these are just a
fraction of the thoughts
that writers have shared about
the craft of telling stories.
How varied are the
authors I've quoted?
works they've created?
How separated in time, in
geography and sensibility.
But if we step back, we see one
thing they all have in common,
and that's the passionate
desire to reach into the hearts
and minds of readers
and make them laugh
or cry or scream in terror.
Somehow, to better understand
this mad world we live in.
And in doing that, to make our
time on Earth a little saner,
a little richer and
frankly, nothing wrong
with it, a little more fun.
And you can quote
me on that last one.
So what I'd like to do
now, I think we have,
I am a little long-winded,
but we have about five
minutes for some questions.
And as you gathered, I do teach.
So if nobody volunteers,
I'm going to call on people.
So, and I think the protocol
is we have a microphone here.
Is that right to take?
If anybody would like to
come forward with a question.
Or over there, someone.
Okay, let me think.
Hmm, oh okay, this
gentleman has saved you there.
Okay, thank you.
>> I'm really curious
about your outlines.
How detailed are they?
>> Jeffery Deaver:
I'm sorry, with the?
>> Your outlines.
>> Jeffery Deaver: Oh how
detailed are my outlines?
They're quite detailed.
They're about 150 pages,
but they're, singe-spaced,
but they only take half the,
they have very big margins.
Why? Because when I
research, I have notebooks
where I transcribe all the
notes I've taken for research,
and I page number those.
So I put my outline in front of
me, and the outline, of course,
8 1/2 by 11, so imagine this
part is completely blank.
I open my notebook that
contains the research,
and I'll see chapter
32, Lincoln Rhyme has
to solve a clue involving
mustard.
And I've done a lot of
research into mustard,
and so I look at my book.
Mustard is on page 42 in the
research, so I write P42 here.
And I go through
the entire outline.
By the time it's finished,
so the outline is done,
all the research is there.
And then I put the
outline in front of me
and just start writing.
That's how it works.
Any other questions?
Oh my goodness, I know we're
well past cocktail hour,
and I do appreciate your
patience coming out.
But yes sir.
>> I'd be interested
to know how you came
up with your character
Lincoln Rhyme.
>> Jeffery Deaver: Where
did Lincoln Rhyme come from?
And if you're not familiar with
him, he is a forensic detective,
ala CSI, although
he predated CSI.
But he's a quadriplegic.
He's paralyzed from the neck
down in an injury
at a crime scene.
And I created him, oddly enough,
as a reaction to what I saw
in popular fiction that I have,
and I am guilty of it myself.
You see it more in thriller
movies where the hero,
it comes down to the end, the
big climatic scene at the end.
And the bad guy is
beating up the good guy.
And it's always,
you know, a little,
we know what's going to happen.
Is there anybody in the
world that doesn't know
that Tom Cruise and Harrison
Ford are going to prevail?
And the Jeremy Irons or Philip
Seymour Hoffman doing the star
turn as the villain
is going to go
down in a big way,
usually over a cliff.
And I thought, there's
nothing wrong with that.
But let's get that twist in.
I like my surprises.
I always have three or four
surprise endings in my books.
So wouldn't it be interesting
if instead of having a gun taped
up under the table that the
hero remembers, or he gets hit
in the head and he remembers
his father taught him
to kickbox when he was eight.
But he had father issues, so
it was a repressed memory.
And then it comes back and beats
the hell out of the bad guy.
How about if my hero
couldn't do that?
He had to outthink the villain.
He had to set up
something in his mind.
Sort of Sherlock Holmes.
That's really where
he came from.
And I frankly never
thought he would be
as popular as he's become.
But, you know, the
comments I get from people
who many are disabled, and
many not, that you know,
we're all our minds first.
Who knows, I don't know karate.
I mean my self-defense is to
look for the exit and run.
That's pretty effective.
But we all are, you
know, our minds
and our hearts and
our souls first.
And I think that's what
Lincoln has embodied.
And I'm working on another one.
You know, I'll keep
writing them for as long
as you're interested
in reading them.
Do we have time for
maybe one more?
Okay, we can get a couple more.
Okay. Yes, please.
>> Well I just wondered
if you believe there's a
book in everyone's life --
>> Jeffery Deaver: I'm
just going to step up here
so I can hear you a little
better if you don't mind.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Jeffery Deaver: No, no, no.
>> Do you believe there's a book
in everyone's life
that can be written?
>> Jeffery Deaver: The
question was a very good one.
Is there a book in everyone's
life that needs to be written?
I'll be honest.
Probably, probably not.
But I'll tell you why, I'll
tell you why I say that.
Because I approach
writing as a, you know,
for me it's a business.
A book is a very, very
difficult thing to construct.
I've learned these
techniques I've told you.
I've learned them over,
well I started writing
when I was 12-years-old.
So a book, no.
But there is a story
that needs to be told.
I wrote, as I mentioned,
a lot of poetry.
I wrote short stories.
I have no art ability.
My sister, Julie Reece Deaver
is a very talented artist
and writer.
She got the art.
But those are ways that
we can tell our stories.
And yes, we have to do that.
A book, I found,
discourages people.
And so the stories within us
don't get out because they start
out by telling a memoir that
is maybe better told in a,
better told in poetry or a
graphic novel or a comic book.
And that's, you know, those
are very serious artforms now.
So yes, tell your story.
But just remember
that, you know,
a 400-page novel may be a
bit, may be a bit daunting.
Could we get, yes,
another one please.
>> I have a double question.
So the first one is
related to criticism.
You were talking
about criticism.
I realized in The Cutting Edge
that these detailed
flipcharts you usually had
in your Lincoln Rhyme
novels, they have to --
>> Jeffery Deaver: I'm sorry,
I'm getting a lot
of feedback here.
I think maybe the
others can hear you.
I'm just going to step up,
because it's a little
hard for me to hear.
>> The flipcharts,
they have disappeared
from The Cutting Edge, so
the detailed flipcharts,
was that part of a reaction to
feedback you got from readers?
That's the first part.
And the second question
would be, what happened
to your other character,
Katryn Dance?
>> Jeffery Deaver: The
question was if you're familiar
with the Lincoln Rhyme books,
I had charts of evidence in all
of them up to The Cutting
Edge, my most recent, the 14th.
And I found that I was getting
a lot of comments from readers
that they didn't read them
because it's very detailed
forensic information.
And I put them in to kind
of orient the reader.
But then I've gotten
feedback over the years
that they were, they
felt guilty.
They didn't read them.
Like they were skimming
over something.
And so I thought I'm
going to leave them out.
And another thing I've done
intentionally, and this,
you might find this
interesting if you're readers,
if you're writers, I've taken
the modern sensibilities
of creative, I call
them products.
But we can say creative
efforts, into mind.
What does that mean?
We binge on TV.
It's a fast-paced life now.
We don't have a lot of time.
My books are a little shorter.
My writing style is a
little more staccato,
shorter sentences,
shorter words.
I will maybe come up with what
I think is an eloquent word
that might mean people
have to look it up.
And I take that out.
I took out the charts.
And you know, I really
am gauging the book
to make it an experience
for everybody.
And like everyone else nowadays,
we want to get the
younger readers involved.
And my books are, you know,
appropriate for say
14-year-old and up.
So, I, you know, that was
a very conscious effort
on my part based on feedback.
The other characters, yes,
Lincoln Rhyme is
the most famous.
And I have to, I
write more of those.
I have, you know, many, many
important people depended on me.
The CEOs of American Express,
Mastercard, Visa and my bank,
Wells-Fargo that has the
mortgage on my house.
So realistically, to be
honest, it's a business.
I make more money with
the Lincoln Rhyme books.
But I have a Kathryn Dance
book in the works and working
on a new series right now.
So I guess that future
plans would be a good way
to say thank you all for coming.
Thank you for your support of
books, and go forth and read.
[ Applause ]